Smart. Less. Media. Sean Hayes and Smartless Media are excited to announce the birth of an all-new baby podcast. The podcast weighs in at a healthy 10 to 12 minutes. Sean Hayes is resting comfortably. This is Clueless. Clueless! Clueless! Clueless! Clueless! I'm Clueless! Woo!
Smart. Less. Media. Sean Hayes 和 Smartless Media 很高兴地宣布，一个全新的播客诞生了。这个播客时长很健康，大约 10 到 12 分钟。Sean Hayes 目前正在舒适地休息。这就是 Clueless。Clueless！Clueless！Clueless！Clueless！我就是 Clueless！噢！
Welcome to episode one of Smartless Presents Clueless a brand new podcast where you, the listener, try to solve puzzles faster than Sean Hayes. My name is Elliot Kalin and I'll be your host because Sean Hayes can't just ask himself the questions, can he? It would be unethical.
欢迎收听 Smartless Presents Clueless 第一期节目，这是一个全新的播客，在节目中，你——听众朋友，将尝试比 Sean Hayes 更快地解开谜题。我的名字是埃利奥特·卡林（Elliot Kalin），我将担任你们的主持人，因为 Sean Hayes 总不能自己问自己问题吧？那太不道德了。
And with me on every episode of this show is the man who loves games more than is really healthy, Mr. Sean Hayes. Sean, how excited are you for this new podcast on a scale from nine to 10? You know, I'm at a 10, but you pick up the slack with your energy, Elliot. It's really infectious.
每期节目陪在我身边的，是对游戏的喜爱已经超过健康程度的男士，肖恩·海耶斯（Sean Hayes）先生。Sean，你对这个新播客的兴奋程度，如果满分是 10 分的话，你给几分？你知道的，我给 10 分，但你得用你的活力来补足我欠缺的部分。这真的很有感染力。
Thank you. And listeners, by the way, this is Elliot Kalin, who you may know was the head writer for Mystery Science Theater 3000, the Daily Show with Jon Stewart, cohost of the bad movie podcast, The Flophouse, and now he's hosting this show for us. Yes.
谢谢。顺便告诉听众朋友们，这位是埃利奥特·卡林（Elliot Kalin），大家可能知道他是《神秘科学剧场3000》（Mystery Science Theater 3000）、乔恩·斯图尔特每日秀（The Daily Show with Jon Stewart）的首席编剧，也是烂片播客《The Flophouse》的联合主持人，现在他正在为我们主持这个节目。是的。
Thank you, thank you. Now, Sean, we should explain to the listener. Okay. What is this show for us. Yes. Thank you, thank you. Now, Sean, we should explain to the listener. What is this show all about? Each episode, you'll be playing a different main game and it might be a word puzzle or identifying a song or choosing the odd one out. That game is called Odd One Out, but it won't just be you competing alone.
谢谢，谢谢。现在，Sean，我们应该向听众解释一下。好吧。我们这个节目到底是干什么的？是的。谢谢，谢谢。现在，Sean，我们应该向听众解释一下。这个节目到底是关于什么的？在每一集里，你会玩一个不同的主游戏，它可能是一个文字谜题、辨别一首歌，或者选出与众不同的那个。那个游戏叫“与众不同”（Odd One Out），但可不只是你一个人在竞争。
You'll also be bringing on a selection of your funny friends and family to play along. Who do we have with us today? It's Will Arnett and Jason Bateman everybody. Hi. Hi. Hi. We're excited. I was trying to harmonize.
你还将邀请你的一些搞笑朋友和家人一起来玩。今天和我们在一起的有谁？大家欢迎威尔·阿奈特（Will Arnett）和杰森·贝特曼（Jason Bateman）。嗨。嗨。嗨。我们很兴奋。我刚才在试图和声。
Will, Jason, welcome to the show. How does it feel to be Sean's funny friends and family? Jason, you're family. I'm family. I'm funny friend. Before we begin, I have to know one thing. Yeah. Jason and Will, what is your Sean Hayes gaming experience up to this point? Has he ever asked you to do it in public before?
Will，Jason，欢迎来到节目。作为 Sean 搞笑的朋友和家人，感觉如何？Jason，你是家人。我是家人。我是搞笑朋友。在开始之前，我必须知道一件事。是的。Jason 和 Will，到目前为止，你们对 Sean Hayes 的游戏体验有什么看法？他以前在公开场合邀请过你们玩吗？
Oh yeah, no, let's keep it clean, okay? We used to gather over at his house for game night. Sean has been with us. We used to play a lot of poker together. I mean, he is a gifted gamer. Let me just say that I got passed over a little bit on the game stuff. You did. And have I forgiven him? Yeah. Wait, I don't remember you being a big person.
哦，是的，别说了，我们说点干净的好吗？我们以前经常去他家聚会玩游戏之夜。Sean 一直和我们在一起。我们以前经常一起打扑克。我的意思是，他是个很有天赋的游戏玩家。我只想说，在游戏方面我稍微被忽略了一点。确实被忽略了。那我原谅他了吗？对。等等，我不记得你当时算是个核心人物。
I don't remember you being a part of the group at that moment. Exactly. No, I wasn't. I wasn't a part of the group. And that's a, it's a bigger conversation. You were always here. Yeah, I was always on your mind. The trip to like Istanbul and stuff, was that before or after game night at your place, Sean? Istanbul was after, but Venice was before. But Venice didn't go very well.
我不记得你当时是这个群体的一员。没错。不，我不是。我不是那个群体的一员。这是一个更深层的话题。你一直都在。对，你一直都在大家的脑海里。像去伊斯坦布尔之类的旅行，是在你家游戏之夜之前还是之后，Sean？伊斯坦布尔是之后，但威尼斯是之前。不过威尼斯去得不太顺利。
No. And-huh. And here we are. Well, now we're new beginnings. But now we're here in new beginnings, Elliott. Now you've really unearthed some old dirt. This will stitch us back together. Maybe it'll launch a podcast of the three of us to be fun. But we're very excited.
没有。然后——呃。然后我们就到了这里。好吧，现在我们有了新的开始。但现在我们在新起点，Elliott。你现在真的挖出了一些陈年旧事。这会把我们重新缝合在一起。也许它会促成我们三个人的播客，那会很有趣。但我们非常兴奋。
I'm very excited. And I know Sean's love of games is deep, very deep. He loves games. Yeah, I like it. It's fun. It's fun. Sean is a master gamer. I love getting that peek inside of your relationship.
我也非常兴奋。我知道 Sean 对游戏的爱很深，非常深。他很喜欢游戏。是的，我很喜欢。这很有趣。这很有趣。Sean 是游戏大师。我很喜欢窥探你们之间的关系。
It briefly turned into a James Bond movie with all the international locations that got thrown into the mix. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah.
由于掺杂了那么多国际地点，它短暂地变成了一部詹姆斯·邦德电影。对。对。对。对。对。
Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah.
对。对。对。对。对。对。对。对。
Yeah. Yeah. Sean, Will, Jason, enough talking about the past. Let's look ahead to the present. Today's main event, it's a numbers game TV show edition. Cue the theme song. Well, it's a numbers game. It's a numbers game.
对。对。Sean，Will，Jason，别再聊过去了。让我们展望现在。今天的重头戏，是数字游戏电视节目版。播放主题曲。好吧，这是一个数字游戏。这是一个数字游戏。
TV show edition. I keep forgetting that there's a band right behind me. Because I saw them load in. I can smell the weed. I keep forgetting there's a band right behind me. Because I saw them load in. I can smell the weed. Yeah, you did. It's a numbers game.
电视节目版。我总是忘了我身后就有一支乐队。因为我看到他们搬器材进来了。我都能闻到大麻味。我总是忘了我身后就有一支乐队。因为我看到他们搬器材进来了。我都能闻到大麻味。是的，你闻到了。这是一个数字游戏。
It's so good. All right, let's begin. This game is built around TV shows with numbers in their titles. You are going to be tested on your very useful knowledge of television shows and also your very useless knowledge of basic elementary school math 227 227 I like that you were so ready with a number right off the bat It will be a winner and one of these questions each question will take the form of a simple math equation
太棒了。好了，我们开始吧。这个游戏的灵感来自于片名中带有数字的电视节目。你们将接受测试，考验你们非常有用的电视节目知识，以及你们非常没用的小学基础数学知识。227，227。我喜欢你一上来就能脱口而出数字。它会成为赢家，在这些问题中，每个问题都将是一个简单的数学方程式。
Only instead of numbers. I'm gonna tell you a TV show title that has had the number removed from it. Oh, shit. You're gonna have to recognize the show, understand the number, and then solve the equation using the missing numbers. And you can get a bonus point as a group for responding with an answer in the form of a TV show title.
只不过，我不会用数字，而是会告诉你一个删掉了数字的电视节目片名。哦，操。你们必须认出这个节目，明白那个数字，然后用缺失的数字解出方程。如果你们能作为一个团队，用一个电视节目片名来回答，就可以获得一个加分。
So I'm gonna give you an example. This is just a practice one. This doesn't count to your score. Let's try this out. If I said, day fiance minus for 30, what would the answer be? And you can talk it out too, work it out between yourselves. 90 day fiance, 30 for 30. So it'd be 60.
所以我来给你们举个例子。这只是个练习。不计入你们的分数。我们来试试这个。如果我说，“90天新郎”（day fiance）减去 30，答案会是什么？你们也可以一起讨论，在你们之间算出答案。90天新郎，30天大限（30 for 30）。所以应该是 60。
Yep, you got that right. And if you wanted that extra point, what is there as a show title with 60 minutes? Oh, 60 minutes. You got it. 60 minutes. Great. You could have also said studio 60 or any of the millions of TV shows that have 60 in their titles. Yeah. Okay, then let's play. It's a numbers game TV show edition.
是的，你们答对了。如果你们想要那个额外的加分，有什么带 60 的节目名字吗？哦，《60分钟》（60 minutes）。答对了。《60分钟》。太棒了。你们也可以说《日落黄沙》（Studio 60）或者数百万个片名中带有 60 的电视节目。好的，那我们开始玩吧。这是一个数字游戏电视节目版。
The first question is million dollar man divided by stooges. Six million dollar man. Yep. Three stooges. Two divided by three is two. Oh, two, and then you gotta do a show with two in it. 227. Nice. You got it, perfect.
第一个问题是：百万富翁（million dollar man）除以三个活宝（stooges）。《无敌金刚》（Six million dollar man）。对。《三个臭皮匠》（Three stooges）。6 除以 3 等于 2。哦，2，然后你们得说出一个带 2 的节目。227。太棒了。答对了，完美。
Two and a half pence. Fuck, you used it. You used it right away. I feel like I should give you double extra points because there's two twos in that name. Yeah, I would like it, I'll take it. Okay, so that's three points total for that first question. You're getting more points than you're supposed to. Hey, hey, hey, a half men. Fucking dummies. 13. 10.
好汉两个半（Two and a half men）。操，你们用了。你们马上就用了。我觉得我应该给你们双倍的额外加分，因为那个名字里有两个 2。对，我想要，我接受。好吧，所以第一题总共是三分。你们得到的的分数比规定的还要多。嘿，嘿，嘿，半个男人。他妈的笨蛋。13。10。
Hang on, hang on. Wait, no. And Reno 911 could be 11. 13 or two ones? Like two stupid sons. I think we gotta go with 11. I think we have to go with 11. Okay, 11 and then what is it?
等等，等等。等等，不。雷诺911（Reno 911）可能是 11。13 还是两个 1？就像两个笨蛋儿子。我觉得我们得选 11。我觉得我们得选 11。好的，11，然后是什么？
I think plus two. Two and a half men. 13. Is 13. And 13 reasons why. Yep, you got it. That's great. Oh, nice. Where's 13 reasons why? Oh, it got it. That's great. Nice.
我觉得加上 2。好汉两个半。13。就是 13。还有《十三个原因》（13 reasons why）。对，答对了。太棒了。哦，太棒了。《十三个原因》在哪里？哦，找到了。太棒了。太棒了。
What's 13 reasons why? Oh, it's a YA vehicle on Netflix. It can be seen massively successful. Young people love it. Young people love it. And I bet it sucks. And I can give you 14 reasons why. Let's go to question three.
什么是《十三个原因》？哦，那是 Netflix 上的一部针对青少年的剧。它非常成功。年轻人很喜欢它。年轻人很喜欢。我敢打赌这剧很烂。我可以给你十四个理由。我们来看第二题。
This one might be a little more difficult. I'm going to try to enunciate as much as I can. Let's go to question three. This one might be a little more difficult. I'm going to try to enunciate as much as I can. This is heaven times company. Seventh heaven. No, seventh heaven times. 21. Wait, wait, 21 Jump Street.
这个问题可能有点难。我会尽量吐字清晰。我们来看第三题。这个问题可能有点难。我会尽量吐字清晰。这是《第七天堂》（Heaven）乘以公司。第七天堂。不，第七天堂乘以。21。等等，等等，《龙虎少年队》（21 Jump Street）。
That's right. You got it. I thought you said something different on the second show. I thought it was six something. It could have been six's company. Who's your cable provider? Because you're doing different shows. Three and a half men, six's company. Yeah. That was very fast, very impressive. You guys are blazing through this game. Let's continue
没错。答对了。我以为你在第二个节目里说了点别的。我以为是六什么公司。可能是《六口之家》（Six's company）。你们的有线电视供应商是谁？因为你们说的节目都不一样。《好汉两个半》，《六口之家》。是的，非常快，非常impressive。你们俩在这款游戏里突飞猛进。我们继续。
at two. Number four. This question is, Beverly Hills, 0 021- is enough. One. Beverly Hills 90210 is enough. We gotta think of the show. Minus eight. Oh one. Murder one. Murder one, very good Will.
到 2。第四题。这个问题是，《飞越比弗利》（Beverly Hills），0021- 够了。1。《飞越比弗利90210》（Beverly Hills 90210）够了。我们得想想那个节目。减去 8。噢 1。《谋杀入门课》（Murder one）。《谋杀入门课》，非常棒，Will。
Yeah, very good. You got it. Murder one, that's two full points. It's just fantastic. Sean, by the way, you suck at this game. I haven't heard one answer from you. Order one that's two full points. It's just fantastic. I'm- Sean, by the way, you suck at this game. I haven't had one answer from you. No, I got the first one.
是的，非常棒。答对了。《谋杀入门课》，整整两分。太棒了。顺便说一句，Sean，你玩这个游戏太烂了。我没听到你回答一个答案。《谋杀入门课》，整整两分。太棒了。我——顺便说一句，Sean，你玩这个游戏太烂了。我没听到你回答一个答案。不，我答了第一个。
Why are you gonna pin in your hand? What are you doing? I'm writing the numbers down. It's obviously helping. Question five. Things I hate about you minus Babylon. What is it? 10 things I hate about you or what is it? What's... Is it 10 things? Is it 10, Elliot? I think it's 10 things I hate about you minus Babylon.
你手里拿个笔干嘛？你在干嘛？我在把数字写下来。这显然有帮助。第五题。《我恨你的十件事》（Things I hate about you）减去巴比伦。是什么？是《我恨你的十件事》还是什么？是什么……是 10 件事吗？是 10 吗，Elliott？我觉得是《我恨你的十件事》减去巴比伦。
Five? Babylon five. Yeah, so it's... Party of five. Great, you got it. Wow. Wow. That was good. That was good. Party of five. Great, you got it. Wow. Wow. That was good. Party of Five. Incredible, Will. You have, you all have such unique strengths that come together as a team. Jason, with the numbers.
5？巴比伦5号（Babylon 5）。对，所以是……《五人派对》（Party of five）。太棒了，答对了。哇。哇。答得好。答得好。《五人派对》，太棒了，答对了。哇。哇。答得好。《五人派对》。太不可思议了，Will。你们都有各自独特的优势，组合在一起成了一个完美的团队。Jason 负责数字。
Will, with the TV shows. Sean, with the writing down the numbers. Yeah. Which is good for record keeping for later. Yeah, yeah, yeah, for sure. Do you consider Sean, would you consider it a compliment if he says your strength is writing stuff down? Yeah.
Will 负责电视节目。Sean 负责把数字写下来。是的。这对以后的记录保存很有好处。对，对，对，肯定的。Sean，如果有人说你的长处是把东西写下来，你会觉得这是在夸你吗？是的。
That's all he could think of. a great day you're gonna have. I'll take anything I can get. Is there, in the Marvel, sorry, in the MCU, is there a superhero? Who's superpowers? Was writing stuff down? The stenographer. He was the stenographer.
这就是他能想到的全部了。你将拥有多么美好的一天啊。只要能捞到什么我都接受。在漫威里，抱歉，在 MCU（漫威电影宇宙）里，有没有哪个超级英雄，他的超能力是把东西写下来？速记员。他就是速记员。
Okay, that was a great game. You guys played an amazing game, but just because you're done with the game does not mean the game is done with you. There's also the matter of this episode's Mega Clue. Mega Clue Question. Beautiful. This is a final question made out of the answers of all the previous questions. So I'm going to remind you what those answers were. I would tell everyone, except Sean doesn't
好的，那是一场精彩的游戏。你们玩了一场精彩的游戏，但这并不意味着游戏已经结束了。接下来还有本期节目的终极线索（Mega Clue）。终极线索问题。太棒了。这是一个根据前面所有问题的答案组合而成的最终问题。所以我来提醒你们这些答案是什么。我要告诉所有人，除了 Sean 不需要
need to know this because he already has it. Everyone take a moment to get a pen, something to write on so I can remind you of what the correct answers were. I take it back on Sean writing it down. It turns out that was smart. If you're driving, lodge your knees just underneath the steering wheel, grab a pen, keep your eyes on the road somewhat. Yeah, if you have a candle on your dashboard, careful.
知道这个，因为他已经知道了。大家花点时间拿支笔、找个能写字的东西，好让我提醒你们正确答案是什么。我收回刚才说 Sean 记下来这事没用的话。事实证明那是明智的。如果你正在开车，把膝盖顶在方向盘下方，抓支笔，眼睛稍微看着路。对，如果你仪表盘上点着蜡烛，小心点。
Sorry, Elliot, there are some. No, no, it's a good point. Set aside the rotisserie chicken that you're picking out with your non-driving hand so you can put a pad there so you can work during that time. Okay, here are the numbers that you have already had as your answers. 2, 13, 21, 1, and 5. Yeah. I'll tell you again. two 13 21
抱歉，Elliott，有些事……不，不，这话说得好。把手里正用非驾驶手撕着的烤鸡放在一边，腾出个地方放记事本，好在开车时做题。好了，以下是你们已经得到的答案数字。2、13、21、1 和 5。是的。我再告诉你一遍。2、13、21
1 and 5 yeah, I'll tell you again 2 13 21 1 and 5 now I want you to add those numbers together 42 and then subtract from that number that was great Then I don't even have a pen with me and I did that in my oh Talk about your superpower mr. math man hey algebra okay now add those numbers together 42 and then subtract the number of monkeys in the title of a television adaptation of a
1 和 5。是的，我再告诉你一遍。2、13、21、1 和 5。现在我要你们把这些数字加起来。42，然后减去那个数字……太棒了。然后我甚至都没带笔，我在脑子里就算出来了。噢。真不愧是你的超能力，数学先生。嘿，代数。好吧，现在把这些数字加起来，42，然后减去一部改编自
1990s science fiction film and then tell, can you think of a show with that number in the title? It'd be 12 monkeys. 13. 34. 34. Oh, so wait, 12 monkeys or eight monkeys? 12 monkeys. 30, 30 something. Is it 30?
20世纪90年代科幻电影的电视剧集片名中的猴子数量，然后告诉我，你能想到一个片名里带有这个数字的节目吗？应该是《十二只猴子》（12 monkeys）。13。34。34。哦，等等，是《十二只猴子》还是《八只猴子》？《十二只猴子》。30，三十而立（30 something）。是 30 吗？
30 something. Oh, wait, what? 42 minus 12, 12 monkeys for 30. And then I was hoping that someone would say 30 something, because it's the rare television show where they spelled out the number They didn't just put a number there. Yeah, that's right. And for one final absolutely last question take that last number and I want you to add it up. Yep.
三十而立。哦，等等，什么？42 减去 12，12只猴子等于 30。然后我本来希望有人能说出《三十而立》，因为那是罕见的把数字拼写出来的电视剧，他们没有直接放一个数字在那里。是的，没错。为了最后一个绝对是最后的问题，把最后一个数字拿过来，我要你们把它加起来。是的。
That's the way we'd end things on smart lists, you know. Take that last number add it to 9970 and can you tell me the name of any pyramids that are worth that much money? Ah. $10,000. The $10,000 pyramid. $100,000.
这就是我们在 smart lists 结束节目的方式，你知道的。把那个数字加上 9970，你能告诉我有哪些金字塔值那么多钱吗？啊。10,000 美元。《一万美元金字塔》（The $10,000 pyramid）。100,000 美元。
You got it. $100,000. Elliot, I put you and this show on the top of a million dollar pyramid, it's so damn good. Yeah. Thanks. Elliot, you're brilliant. Thanks, I appreciate it.
答对了。《十万美元金字塔》。Elliott，我觉得你和这个节目简直能排在百万富翁金字塔的顶端，太棒了。谢啦。Elliott，你太聪明了。谢谢，我很感激。
It's a lot of fun, it's a lot of fun, Elliot. You know, it's a hoot, you guys. Yeah. Thanks. Elliot, you're brilliant. It's a lot of fun. It's a lot of fun, Elliot. You know it's a hoot, you guys. Clueless. Listeners at home, did you do better or worse than these actual 100% authentic famous people? If you did better, maybe you should be famous. Your mom keeps telling me how talented you are. Think about it.
这太有趣了，这太有趣了，Elliott。你知道的，这太棒了，伙计们。是的。谢啦。Elliott，你太聪明了。这太有趣了。这太有趣了，Elliott。你知道这太棒了，伙计们。Clueless。家里的听众朋友们，你们的表现比这些百分之百根正苗红的名人好还是坏？如果你们表现得更好，也许你们也该成名。你妈妈一直在告诉我你有多有天赋。考虑一下吧。
Sean, Will, Jason, thank you so much for being with us today. I'll be very sad to see you go. So it's a good thing the show's not over yet because every episode of Clueless ends with the cliffhanger puzzle. Sting music there it is. You wanted more sting music you got it. Heavy bass line. The cliffhanger puzzle is just a little bit of extra puzzle. We put it in a tougher way for you to take home and pick at it until the next episode and today's puzzle takes the form, today's puzzle takes the form of a little story.
Sean，Will，Jason，非常感谢你们今天来到这里。看到你们离开我会很难过。所以好消息是节目还没结束，因为 Clueless 的每一期节目都是以悬念谜题结束的。刺痛音乐，来了。你们想要更多的刺痛音乐，给你们安排上。低沉的贝斯线。悬念谜题只是一道额外的趣味小谜题。我们把它做得更有挑战性，让你们带回家去琢磨，一直琢磨到下一期节目。今天的谜题形式是，今天的谜题是一个小故事的形式。
It seems that the energy drink Prime Hydration has been so successful that the company celebrated by creating two solid gold Prime bottles. The gold bottles are an appropriate vessel for the drink. Silver bottles would also be appropriate, but iron or tin bottles would not be. Why is that the case? That's for you to noodle over until our next episode.
看起来，能量饮料 Prime Hydration 取得了巨大的成功，以至于该公司通过打造两瓶纯金 Prime 水瓶来庆祝。纯金水瓶是这种饮料的合适容器。银质水瓶也是合适的，但铁制或锡制水瓶就不合适了。这是为什么呢？这就是留给你们在下一期节目之前去琢磨的问题。
Sean, Will, Jason, are you guys going to get any sleep between now and the moment you learn the answer to this puzzle? Not if I get all hopped up on prime beverage. Yeah, I'm going to sleep great. I'm going to be able to do that. Maybe even better. Maybe a little better than normal. I mean, Elliot, I gotta say, just the very end
Sean，Will，Jason，从现在到你们得知这个谜题答案的这段时间里，你们还能睡得着觉吗？如果我狂喝 Prime 饮料，我就睡不着。对，我会睡得很香。我能做到这一点。甚至可能更好。可能比平时稍微好一点。我的意思是，Elliott，我得说，就在你的问题快结束的时候，
of your question, I was just entering REM. We'll reveal the answer to today's cliffhanger puzzle at the top of our next episode, which guess what? You can listen to right now. Just click the link in this episode description to follow us on Apple podcasts or search for Smartless Presents Clueless in your podcast app of choice. Make sure to follow, subscribe, rate, review, all the things that you can do to let us know
我刚刚进入快速眼动睡眠（REM）。我们将在下一期节目的开头揭晓今天悬念谜题的答案，猜猜怎么着？你现在就可以收听。只需点击本节目简介中的链接，在苹果播客上关注我们，或者在你的首选播客应用中搜索 Smartless Presents Clueless。记得关注、订阅、评分、评论，所有你能做的事情，让我们知道
you love this show. And with that, this first episode of Clueless must come to an end. Will, Jason, thank you so much for joining us. Sean, thank you for being Sean Hayes. Somebody has to. I'm glad you took the burden. It's exhausting. Yeah. And as long as I'm just handing out thank yous, why don't I Somebody has to. I'm glad you took the burden off. It's exhausting. Yeah.
你喜欢这个节目。说到这里，第一期 Clueless 节目也要接近尾声了。Will，Jason，非常感谢你们的加入。Sean，谢谢你做 Sean Hayes。总得有人来做。我很高兴你卸下了这个包袱。这太累人了。是的。既然我在发感谢信，为什么我不……总得有人来做。我很高兴你把它卸下来。这太累人了。是的。
And as long as I'm just handing out thank yous, why don't I toss one to the audience as well? Thank you, audience, for listening to this show. This has been Clueless. We'll be back next episode with more puzzles and more Sean Hayes, not necessarily in that order. I've been your host, Elliot Kalin, reminding you to join us next time because if you give us less than 24 hours notice, we still have to charge you for the appointment.
既然我在发感谢信，为什么我也向观众抛出一个呢？谢谢观众收听这个节目。这就是 Clueless。下一期节目我们将带着更多谜题和更多的 Sean Hayes 回归，顺序不分先后。我是你们的主持人 Elliott Kalin，提醒大家下次还要来，因为如果你给我们少于 24 小时的通知，我们仍然要收取你的预约费。
Goodbye. Yay. Very nice. Thank you, guys. Thank you, Elliot. You have been listening to Smartless Presents Clueless, a Smartless media production in association with SiriusXM. Your host is Elliot Kalin, who also writes our scripts. Your constant contestant is Sean Hayes, who is 5'11". Your producer, editor, and engineer is Devon Torrey-Brindt, who is me. I also write all engineer is Devon Torrey Bryant who is me I also write all the music and sound effects assistant engineer Kyle McGraw
再见。耶。非常棒。谢谢你们。谢谢你，Elliott。您收听的是由 Smartless Media 联合 SiriusXM 制作的 Smartless Presents Clueless。您的主持人是编写我们剧本的 Elliott Kalin。您的常驻嘉宾是身高 5 英尺 11 英寸的 Sean Hayes。您的制作人、剪辑师兼音响师是 Devon Torrey-Brindt，也就是我。我还编写了所有的音响师是 Devon Torrey Bryant，也就是我。我还编写了所有的音乐和音效，助理音响师是 Kyle McGraw。
today's puzzles were written by Matt Broussard and Josh Richmond talent producer is Anne Harris associate producer Maddy McCann social media producer Tommy Galgano executive producers are Elliott Kaelin Sean Hayes Will Arnett and Jason Bat Bateman. Executive Producers for Smartless Media are Richard Corson and Bernie Kaminsky. Remember to follow, subscribe, rate, and review the show. It really helps. That's all for now. We will see you again for more Clueless.
今天的谜题由 Matt Broussard 和 Josh Richmond 编写，艺人制作人是 Anne Harris，副制作人是 Maddy McCann，社交媒体制作人是 Tommy Galgano，执行制作人是 Elliott Kaelin、Sean Hayes、Will Arnett 和 Jason Bateman。Smartless Media 的执行制作人是 Richard Corson 和 Bernie Kaminsky。记得关注、订阅、评分和评论节目。这真的很有帮助。今天就到这里。我们下期节目再见，继续收看更多的 Clueless。
Clueless. I'm Clueless! There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
Clueless。我就是 Clueless！本期节目暂无评论。点击字幕中的任意句子即可发表评论。